at home setting for the golden globe
nominees meant they were watching on the
couch with their loved ones and friends
jennifer aniston posted on her instagram
that nominee jason bateman and his kids
were actually
zooming from her house for the show kate
hudson had the whole family
at her place including goldie hawn and
kurt russell as she was nominated for
the film music
yeah in a very surprising moment nicole
kidman
and keith urban were on the couch with
their two daughters
12 year old sunday and 10 year old faith
we almost never see
sunday i can never remember seeing them
ever
post them on social media and never
brings them to red carpets but last
night we got to see them hanging out
with mom
and her louis vuitton dress yeah and
then
jody foster played vague about her
sexuality when
she accepted the sissel d the mill award
at the globes in 2013 she was happy to
share her win
this year with her wife jody foster
[Applause]
oh my god i love my wife thank you alex
and ziggy just how supportive your wife
has been
oh yeah she's the best
she's the best this is the best globes
ever
to be able to be home but also it just
felt really real
it didn't feel like it was filled with
so much artifice i think people were
kind of
thrilled by the newness and the sort of
live theater of it all
um it's really special
oh yeah so what do you make of this
storm's says smart mother might not
nicole not having her kids on camera all
the time but yeah fascinating that
this at home setting just like removes
those barriers for celebrities
right but it's true when it's lucky
thurman and nicole came up
it's for kids like i've never seen them
before uh but
i think that's part of it even jason's
today because like just everyone just
felt
dif it felt different because you were
home and to in my moment was um
isaac when he was with his daughter uh
winning from menari and her daughter
his daughter jumps on her on him and
she's like i prayed i prayed it was just
i was like oh my god
he's getting this moment with his
daughter how special is this
uh but yeah i think it's a reflection of
our life now in in 2020 and 2021 and
uh you know people dressed up and they
were sitting on their couch and having
some golden globe
uh glamour moments but it was beautiful
to see the families and their pets there
was a lot of pets
uh the awkward moments graham were where
you know when they go to break and they
were forcing them to interact i was like
right that was weird that didn't really
work
yeah francis says such an amazing moment
for jody
yeah i mean i just found this
fascinating i mean yeah because i looked
up
um jody's speaks from 2013 and that's
actually before she met alex her wife
she met her in 2014
but jody did a whole setup about oh i
have something to reveal tonight
you know i'm really nervous about
revealing this i need your support in
the room basically said that she's going
to say she's gay and then she says i'm
single
so she kind of played into that but then
same thing about her sexuality in that
speech and then flash forward
seven years she's winning an award
kissing your wife on camera you know
acknowledging her as as her wife and
then yeah nicole kidman i mean
i wonder if like did they even register
for nicole kidman that
you are even though you're sitting at
home nicole came in this is being shown
to
millions and millions of people around
the world like she's so guarded about
her kids
like i don't know maybe yeah register on
the same level that you realize
i i'm sure they had a huge discussion on
that they were like yeah they were
wearing the same clothes
like everyone's matching it was like
perfectly like it was like a photo right
the way they were sitting it was just i
think they thought that
through all of it and uh maybe it was
time maybe because their kids are older
and they can acknowledge if they want to
be on camera or not
and they can make their own decision but
those were the moments even like jason
bateman like i don't think i've ever
seen his kids either
so you know kate hudson had the whole
family there
and uh it goes on and on but uh that's
what made this so
unique it was the best and worst golden
globes i've ever seen but
what have made it so great is the fact
that they got to share with their family
at that moment